tens of thousands of dollars worth of
belongings just gone now a local woman
hoping somebody can track down what was
stolen from a moving truck including her
father's ashes madison kimbrough live
near the strip where that incident
madison happened last week
jennifer houser is still very much in
disbelief that she was robbed of almost
all of her personal belongings it
happened right here at the oyo hotel and
casino as she was about to move back to
san diego when this unfortunate event
took place last week
jennifer houser and her boyfriend have
lived in las vegas for years and
recently they decided to move back to
san diego to start up their own business
but things didn't go according to plan
when in the midst of moving they were
robbed of all their personal belongings
this happening at the oil hotel and
casino located right off the strip their
belongings were located inside of a
u-haul they had planned to drive during
the move the security said you know what
park it in the employee parking lot and
it'll be fine we watch it there that's
where our employees park so we thought
ok and it was the first night but
overnight their truck was gone having
had some mechanical problems prior
jennifer thought u-haul may have come
and switched out the truck maybe u-haul
came and got it we called them they
didn't have it
we thought we talked to the security
they didn't tow it so
then we filed a police report metro
contacted jennifer a little over a day
later saying that they had found the
u-haul truck in the northeast part of
the valley however nothing was left
inside she had everything from clothes
to sports equipment to several pounds of
jewelry all worth up to a hundred
thousand dollars but the most precious
item she says can never be replaced my
dad's ashes i don't know if they
if they
i don't even think they would know ashes
are in there but
i mean that's the most thing i'm most
concerned about my son's baby stuff like
when he was born i made a box for him
like
everything like
pictures of him when he was a baby his
first hat he wore everything
as for hotel security cameras jennifer
says she has not seen any surveillance
footage yet but if you have seen or know
anything about her belongings or where
they might be you are urged to contact
police immediately reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now